obviously the ever unfolding situation
involving now 16 at last count
there could be more assault lawsuits
filed against watson
that creates an issue that
will be behind him at some
point yeah he will move on from this
at some point i believe i don't think
he's going to be
in a situation where he never plays
football again
because of this chris and the short-term
complication
could become longer term depending upon
what the nfl does and how long these 16
cases or up to 24 or
more take to resolve right but this
we've seen this before i don't want to
name names i don't want to go down
memory lane here with other guys who and
in the moment
it looked like they'd never play again
and ultimately they did play again sure
and ultimately it did get behind them
now
a lot of this is controlled by the way
watson handles himself going forward
but that is an important point to
remember it's
some juncture in the future
who knows how far in the future but at
some point
this will be behind him and will be
behind everyone who's paying attention
to it and to the extent that there is
any responsibility on his part
hopefully he will find a way to make
proper amends and the victims if there
are victims not alleged victims will be
able to move on
as well they're part of this story too
but at some point
we believe this will be over just
as we sit here today who knows when that
will be
i mean it's it affects a few teams in
the nfl
i'm sure and now they're probably you
know i think about the carolina panthers
they're probably oh no you know we were
sitting back here kind of hoping we'd
get a chance or a crack at making a
trade for the guy
now we now we might definitely have to
go to the draft and figure out you know
plan b
plan c you know of course the miami
dolphins it seems like they've moved on
uh i think but we don't know that for
sure either but i think they're a team
that we both know was very interested if
it became available
and the texans had the conversation but
like mike do you really believe it
do you really believe by the time like
and i'm not trying to dispute john
mcclane like we've talked about the
other day he's the man he's a legend
down in houston
and when he talks about anything down
there i listen but do you really think
at this point where we
sit you know basically a little more
than a month out from the draft that
this is going to get cleared up in in in
that amount of time to where
teams are now going to call the texans
to try to trade them like what's your
gut say there
well i think it's going to take a lot to
get to the point before right
this draft right where that can happen
yes because
of the sheer volume of claims the time
that it takes for the civil justice
system to move forward the possibility
of a criminal prosecution the ever
looming possibility
of placement of desean watson on the
commissioner exempt list and i think
back to 2019 with antonio brown when he
was just facing
one claim for sexual assault right
the nfl's unwillingness to tell teams
whether or not he would be placed on the
commissioner exempt list
paralyzed and froze in place
any interest any effort because the
concern was we're going to sign this guy
and as soon as we do he's going to be
placed on paid leave we're going to be
paying him to not play why would we do
that we're not going to sign him
until we know that he's going to be able
to play and of course the nfl didn't
tell anybody what they were going to do
and
in this case the possibility that watson
could eventually be put on paid leave
would be one of the major reasons why a
team would not trade for him because
then you have a guy that you're going to
pay 10 million in a year with a reduced
cap
right you're gonna pay 10 million to a
guy that doesn't play at all this year
and you're looking at 35 million in
salary in 2022
if it isn't resolved by then here's
the key and there were some developments
yesterday we finally heard from
rusty hardin who issued a statement
there was
an affidavit declaration whatever you
want to call it written testimony
from a business manager who works with
deshaun watson regarding one of these
claims
we'll get into those details as we
discuss this
topic throughout this segment of and you
know
why are you talking about desean watson
because there's news again there's news
again there's 16 cases
and watson's lawyer has put out a
statement that has
several things that are worth discussing
but let me just say this because it
dovetails with
whether or not there's any way he could
be traded
by the draft right and and this dawned
on me last night and people have asked
me
since i practiced law how would you
handle it what would you do would you
represent him
what advice would you give him and my
advice for him right now
independent of whether or not he's
guilty and i would
and and look it's we're in no position
to opine with any certainty on that all
we know is but it doesn't there's a lot
of people
who are accusing him of misconduct i
would advise him
as aggressively as i could and i
probably would
disengage from helping him if he refused
this advice
my advice would be to set up a mediation
session mediation has become extremely
popular over the last 30 35 years as a
way
for resolving civil claims without tying
up the resources
of the justice system because in most
jurisdictions
the judges are there both for criminal
cases and civil cases and they don't get
paid by the case they don't get paid by
the hour they get paid as michael scott
says by the year
they get a salary that's it no matter
how many or how few
cases they have and if they have too
many cases over a sufficient period of
time they just get another judge
but you go through periods of time where
you're extremely busy until the
legislature
or other appropriate governmental
entities gives you another judge to take
some of this workload
so right the judges like it very much
when the parties decide on their own to
find a way to settle the case and
mediation is very popular and what you
do is you find a retired judge
who will have the right presence the
right demeanor create the sense of a
quasi day
in court where everyone gets together
and they hash out some of the issues
in an initial meeting although you don't
have to go into
extensive detail and you don't want to
get people upset
in this initial meeting and then you
break out into sessions where
you you try to work the cases out and
something happens i've i've been
involved
as the lawyer representing the defendant
in a civil case
the plaintiff in a civil case and i've
been the mediator there's something that
happens when you bring everyone together
with a genuine interest in trying to
resolve their issues
right and if there's interest on on both
sides and you've got
16 up to 24 different people
who may feel different ways right
and all it takes is one to say no i want
my day in real court
and i don't care if i win or lose i want
my rights to be vindicated i want to
have a chance to testify about what this
guy did to me
okay that that all it takes is one right
what i'm saying
yeah you have to this is where this is
where tony busby needs to get his
clients under control and explain to
them that there are many forms of
justice
and the fact that they're all proceeding
with a pseudonym
would tell me that they would prefer not
to have to go into open court
and tell their story right seems that
way because they haven't yeah
so so again i'm trying to find a way to
thread the popcorn here
to make this end
i don't want to say make it go away
because it's something that needs to be
dealt with
deshaun watson needs to deal with it he
needs to have some sort of reckoning
whether
it's because of misconduct during these
massages or because of this
habit yeah this what what whatever
whatever it was that possessed him
to search through instagram for his
massage therapist
and and he here's where and this is what
pushed me over the edge to say you just
got to settle this because
chris what rusty harden thinks
is a silver bullet is not a silver
bullet
and this gets to one of the big flaws in
the presentation of evidence from
yesterday
yeah you got 16 people who are claiming
misconduct
and they focused on one claim
and the argument is that there's
one woman who
engaged in consensual sexual activity
with deshaun watson and then tried to
blackmail him for thirty thousand
dollars to not talk about it
okay okay and brian bernie issues the
statement explaining the
the back and forth and and and he he
said to this woman's business manager
this is extortion and the guy said it's
not extortion it's blackmail like that
makes it okay
like that's the story that brian bernie
tells and and the argument
two problems number one the argument
from harden
that and i'm i'm trying to find the
exact language here
that finding one of these 16 that was
trying to blackmail or extort watson
calls into question the legitimacy of
the other cases
it doesn't there's too many yeah if
there was two or three others maybe it
does
right if there's 16 it doesn't and
beyond that chris
it's an admission that this is exactly
what watson was doing
he was looking for massages with the
opportunity for it to turn sexual
yeah because they're admitting he did it
he did it with one of these people
and she wanted 30 000 on the back end to
not talk about it so
that for me was the moment where i said
it's time for watson
to write whatever checks he has to write
right to these 16 individuals to buy out
these lawsuits
and move forward because i don't see a
way this ends well no for him if he
decides to dig in and fight no way
there's no way it ends well
i don't get that either all right mike
let me ask you this like now
if he settles this right and i mean i
saw your article yesterday and and
everything you wrote last night i mean
it makes a lot of sense i really agree
with just about everything you wrote
you know he's in a no-win situation you
know at this point
yeah of his own making of his own making
of his own mind even if he didn't engage
in insult
he created this message yes by deciding
to go to instagram to find
a string of massage therapists up to 24.
exactly right sorry all right no yeah
you're good i'm glad i'm glad you
explained that
now what if they settle with the 16
right and do that is there anything to
stop
moore from coming out later and then
having to deal with it like
you know we have 16 there's maybe 24 out
there
okay the 16 gets settled with now those
eight that we talked about
might be out there they look at the
money and go get them to the table too
you got to get everybody on the table
yeah
yeah i think basically everybody yeah
part of the process is you try to make
sure you've got
all of them and just the mere fact that
you would have to engage in a
brainstorming session with desean watson
is that all are there more are there
more
are there more that in and of itself
yeah
reinforces my belief this needs to be
resolved he needs to find a way to get
this behind him
and the last thing he should do is fight
because chris if there's other
others out there that could be part of
this effort to resolve the case
that means there's others out there that
could still sue him right and the only
time those cases go away
is once the statute of limitations
expires so
i just the the the simple fact that
you'd have to
sit down and with a calendar and try to
recreate
all the different times you had massage
therapists that you found on social
media
i it's all the more reason all the more
reason
to get this resolved now the other side
of it chris doesn't make the nfl go away
no that's now that the nfl is activated
it's yeah it's it's
and but you know what at this point you
you deal with
it yeah you d you you get [ __ ] it's
your own fault that you're in this mess
you get it you get it resolved in a way
that that
is yeah you know it and and what i what
i always said at mediation was the best
outcome is both sides are a little bit
upset
you know no one gets everything they
want but they get resolution and they
can move on with their lives
and uh after that happens whatever it
takes to resolve
those cases then you have to sit back
and see what the nfl will do
and even though is the nfl
more lenient or strict when they see
okay now you've paid out and settled in
the civil suit are they
is that in the nfl's eye like a look of
guilt basically
yeah i mean how do they look at that
well
here's the reality yeah and we know this
from experience whether it's ezekiel
elliott
i mean i can we can rattle off 10 15
different names they're going to do
whatever they want to do
yeah and we don't know and they don't
tell you in advance
what they're going to do i remember when
adrian peterson
was dealing with his situation in 2014
arising from aggressive over discipline
of his child
his small child there was
a belief from what i was told at the
time that the way he handled it the way
it was resolved rusty hardin was
involved in that case by the way the way
that criminal case was resolved
there was an understanding that things
would go one way with the nfl and it
didn't go that way right
the nfl can do whatever it wants the way
the personal conduct policy has been set
up the nfl has the discretion
and the leeway to do whatever it chooses
in any given case and remember
ben roethlisberger chris he was sued for
rape in 2009
and then in 2010 there was the incident
in georgia for which he was nearly
prosecuted
i still believe there was a settlement
to
to give that victim or alleged victim
her sense of justice right and short
circuit of prosecution but that didn't
stop the nfl
from disciplining roethlisberger he was
suspended six games reduced to four
to start the 2010 season so i can see
the nfl
even if you settle these cases with a
confidentiality clause that necessarily
prevents any of the 24
or more from talking to the nfl and the
nfl has no subpoena power
they could still bring into sean watson
they could grill desean watson
and the sheer volume and the magnitude
of the distraction that he's created the
tarnishing of the shield
he could still get suspended for that
now how long of a suspension would it be
you you could you could look at it and
say well the fact that he
eliminated the distraction by resolving
these cases
is a positive yeah for him in the eyes
of the league it also could be a
negative because they can look at it and
say
you clearly did something you shouldn't
have done yeah so we're going to be more
inclined to
suspend you i i think like i i just have
a hard time thinking that he will not
get suspended really at this point
you know just because uh he's too big of
a figure
there's too many things that are wrong
about the situation
you know whether he's guilty or not like
we said we're not trying to do that
but but it there's the nfl is gonna i
think want to set an example a little
bit here to be like
listen i don't care who you are you're
one of the five best players in the
league whatever
this can't go down and anything about it
we're not even judging what happened
inside the massage rooms or anything
like that the way it went down
the way it looks is that just it's a bad
example for for all players
let alone you know of course what we're
hearing and some of the details and all
that i just i have a hard time thinking
the nfl won't kind of
you know take a tough stance here with
this one and like
mike let me ask you this too like i
don't
i i mean i'm with you i want to go back
to something you said earlier like
what good did it do i don't think it did
any good to tell
the fact that you were getting a massage
therapist and really basically paying
for
consexual sex or non-consensual sex or
whatever
i mean that i mean i go back to what you
said that's the thing that popped out to
me last night reading the article
that was basically an admission of guilt
right there
i mean i i i mean it looks like to me to
where i just think the nfl is going to
be able to look at that and go
well you said it on this one there are
16 cases there's
you know eight other ones and you know
this doesn't look good and we think
probably you had the same intentions
with all the other ones to go along with
that and that's where
i don't understand that i'm i'm really
shocked like that you know
uh mr harden whatever the hell his first
name is rusty excuse me
i'm shocked that he let that be out
there was it worth to say
one person was blackmailing or extorting
us
to let that out of the bag to let it
known that yes this is what he does he
gets on
instagram and tries to find therapists
and
pay for conces consensual sex i don't
know if that was worth it to let that
out there
no i think that's the problem that's the
silver bullet that becomes the boomerang
and yeah right when you when you take
the step back and you look at this it
takes
off the table any defense for deshaun
watson premised on
there was never any attempt to secure
sexual favors yeah that's all these were
massages remember we talked about this
last week right these are massages of
sensitive areas
it's a an inherently intimate act
and the if you're massaging the upper
groin there may be incidental contact
sure with things and yeah or if you're
massaging the gluteus there may you know
it's a
and and that's gone now that's out the
window yeah because
he admits through his lawyers that there
was consensual sex
with one of these individuals so you
can't say well it was just one
it wasn't all of them because it does it
creates the image
and the perception and the reality that
these were not
traditional massages these were massages
with a wink
and a nod and the problem he's now into
it's
there's two ways this goes as it relates
to the alleged victims
either it was
aggressive conduct by him that crossed
the line
yeah or or there was consensual
conduct that now that this is all out
there
maybe it wasn't consensual maybe they
were kind of okay with it at the time or
you know but but there's never going to
be a persuasive argument from watson's
camp
that i just i that's not i that's not
what i do i'm just getting massages what
are you talking about sexual activity
during massages no these are just
massages
that to me that hurts
his entire defense and that's that's one
of the big reasons why i said last night
it's time for this time to settle and
and listen professional athletes out
there to the extent any of you
are watching the show today or listening
to it on siriusxm211 and if you are
during your workout or whatever we
appreciate that very much
listen to the advice of the people you
have around you to give you advice this
is not a time when you're in a
spot like this to be stubborn yeah if
you're young and you're stubborn the
problem is
you don't have the life experience to
understand how these situations unfold
and innocent or guilty
the moment for desean watson
to recognize there was a problem that
needed to be taken seriously and not
flatly denied was when the first case
came his way but apparently however it
was handled yeah
it it it lit the fuse for 16 or up to 24
more
tony busby may have been content to just
resolve this one
quietly the first one and that would
have been the end of it and we never
would have known about it i had an agent
tell me over the weekend that
that over the course of the past year on
behalf
of his clients there had been three
occasions
where someone made a claim yep they
thought it was they thought it was
frivolous they thought it was wrong and
it wasn't a sexual thing just different
things
you said something to somebody you
bumped it or whatever which
and you write the check and you move on
because you don't want the headache that
comes from the media coverage
and the potential for litigation and
everything that can flow from that chris
and there's wisdom in that now the the
real wisdom is don't do stuff like this
if you're guilty yeah
right but the separate business side of
it is
there's a point where you got to take
your medicine and there's a point where
you have to face your reckoning and if
there's a way you can face your
reckoning before it explodes
that's the better way to face your
record well definitely it looks like
really that you know watson got wind of
this right
the situation what was gonna go down he
makes that definitive statement on
twitter
probably at that time just thinking it's
gonna be one person
right and hoping that this one thing go
this one person one thing he can fight
it and go away
but you know what i'm shocked by a
little bit is yeah
to your point of what you're talking
about with players this is where you got
to be really honest with the people
around you to help you
and yeah before you send that message
out to twitter
you talk to whether an agent or
something and go hey this is going on
blah blah blah
and honestly listen it's not just this
one person
i i it could be fishy with five ten
other people whatever you gotta be
honest there then maybe where that
person advises you and goes okay no no
don't set out
set you know send send out that
tweet that you know makes it sound like
you're totally innocent and how dare
anybody criticize me or
or try to punish me for this action you
know so
that is where you talk about advice
coming in handy but like
now mike to everything you've said it's
over
it is over like there's no way
you can't go to court or do any of this
you've already lost the perception is
what it is
everybody's going to look at desean
watson and think oh it's a little weird
right okay but i think the best
you know road or avenue is like you're
saying
get in a room settle it you're gonna
have to write a really big
check but i think that all expedites
you know the whole process and gets to
sean back to what he really wants to do
which is trying to forget this and play
football once again
and i think the bottom line you know
with all these women and everything else
that's what desean watson wants to do he
does want to play football we know that
and the reality is this and i want to be
clear about this the process of going
through mediation
is intended to give the individuals who
have made these claims
against watson a fair shake something
that feels like a day in court
and something that allows them to
believe that justice was done that a
reckoning was
had that their message was heard that
they spoke truth to power
and fame and desean watson
and all other professional athletes or
anyone else with
power and fame and money will know that
these are not appropriate activities in
which to engage so there's a way to do
this
and satisfy the interest of everyone
involved and i just think that
the best way to do it is to do it now
to do it informally and to do it before
you
start going to court and setting
schedules for trial and having
depositions
set where the individuals testify
and then deshaun watson at some point
has to testify chris
here's another reason this is the most
important reason i think
setting aside whatever it would cost to
defend himself
from beginning to end of litigation even
if you win
the legal fees for this many cases will
be astronomical
setting that aside setting aside
whatever the nfl may do to him
by way of an unpaid suspension set that
aside set aside the possibility of
significant verdicts
that you would have to pay to these
individuals if you lose
all the cases at trial set all that
aside
you can still go to jail and
even though i've said case like this
difficult to prove beyond a reasonable
doubt
that there was some sort of criminal
misconduct very difficult when you're
talking about
the versions of two different people but
here here's what happens
if you defend the civil cases you're
going to be called to testify
at some point what do you do do you take
the fifth
do you invoke your right against self
incrimination right here
to protect yourself right in the
criminal cases if you do that
criminal lawyer would say do that don't
talk you could still be prosecuted yeah
you're gonna lose
every civil case in which you get on the
witness stand after
the plaintiff has told her story of all
these things that you did and your
response is
i invoke my right against
self-incrimination those cases are done
and if you do testify you set yourself
up to be twisted into knots by an
experienced and
skilled interrogator who will
potentially
allow you to give the prosecution
a transcript of your own words that will
be used
to fuel your prosecution right that's
another
light bulb i had multiple light bulbs
that finally went off from me last night
after i looked at rusty
something finally working in that brain
digested it yeah well thank you
but but and and you know and and here's
here i want to i wanted to ask you
one chris let me say one last thing yeah
go ahead this this just shows that
when when the lawyer finally comes
forward on behalf of deshaun watson the
statement
does more harm than good seems like it
it does seem like it because yeah
well you know we got a little you know
inkling
into okay it seems like you know
consensual paid massage
goes on right okay all right that's a
little weird
but what what what what i think really
hurt them too and i i wanted to hit on
this just for a second is
you know now busby reacts to
hardin's statement and the fact that
you know maybe mr hardin doesn't know
all the things that mr busby knows yet
right to now where busby says something
about
you know what was the the part the nda
that they have
they they have evidence that he was
trying to make these massage therapists
sign ndas right before or after some of
these massages
that's weird i mean that that doesn't
look good either like
bam strike you know 17. tony busby gets
another strike out there with something
else he does on social media
and that didn't look good for watson or
rusty hardin either
yeah harden's statement criticizes
busby's antics and
says he created a circus-like atmosphere
well you know what
ultimately it's been effective you may
not
like the methods i don't like the
methods
they wouldn't mesh with my own personal
style but you know what what busby has
done
has been extremely effective no doubt
the court of public opinion and also
on the broader chessboard of how these
cases will play out in court
or prior to court and the consequences
potentially
for desean watson civilly criminally
and professionally and we mentioned
earlier
the ben roethlisberger case that was 11
years ago there may be people who
completely forget about it there may be
people who never even knew about it at
all so much time has passed
but when ben roethlisberger faced the
claim
of misconduct in georgia in 2010
and there ultimately was no prosecution
and again
i still continue to believe that there
was a confidential settlement of claims
which is a perfectly legitimate way
for justice to be dispensed if the
plaintiff slash accuser is satisfied
with that outcome
so be it money changing hands is how
justice is done in the civil justice
system and that can sometimes
short-circuit
a prosecution when it was all said and
done
here is the key portion
from the letter that roger goodell sent
to ben roethlisberger explaining
the suspension i recognize the
allegations in georgia were disputed
they did not result in criminal charges
being filed against you
my decision today is not based on a
finding that you violated georgia law
or on a conclusion that differs from the
local prosecutor
that said you are held to a higher
standard
as an nfl player and there is nothing
about your conduct
that can remotely be described as
admirable
responsible or consistent with either
the values of the league
or the expectations of our fans right
your conduct
raises sufficient concerns that i
believe effective intervention
now is the best step for your personal
and professional
welfare you could take that paragraph
and copy paste apply yeah that's what
deshaun watson's current situation right
because even if we don't find out
anything else
we know enough to say that his conduct
raises sufficient concerns that
effective intervention now is the best
step
for his personal and professional
welfare
case closed yeah chris yeah no i i hear
you and you know when
in that statement you know your your
conduct is
you know held to a different level i'm
paraphrasing here as far as you know
you're an nfl player
i think there's another you know up the
ante when you're talking about a
franchise quarterback that the league is
even going to be
you know more critical of these type of
guys the ben roethlisbergers the deshawn
watsons because they are the faces of
the nfl
and this is one where you know yeah
people don't want
the nfl is not going to want people to
look at this and go oh well they led
desean watson off easy
you know he's a star quarterback so
they're not going to do that i think
it's actually going to make it
you know more of a hard stance from the
nfl on this issue because of
you know the star power that desean
watson has
yeah so look i
we we we've we've tried to be as
balanced
as we can we've tried to be as fair as
we can
and we've reacted to the news as the
news has come to us
i i just i think that now is the time
yep settle settle
but but the the bigger the bigger the
bigger reckoning here
is that deshaun watson has engaged in
behaviors that he should not have
engaged in he should not have been
trolling social media for massage
therapy
plus which is what
based upon the effort to knock out all
the cases by showing blackmail in the
instance of one
that that seems to be yeah what he was
doing right
and it wasn't an isolated occurrence it
wasn't
two or three times it was a pattern
a practice a way of life
and that look this is this is
where you need to have people around you
who can tell you hard truths and can
can bust through the facade
of youth and fame
and inexperience and money and
i don't want to say arrogance in a
pejorative way there's just a natural
amount of
healthy quarterback i'm the guy
arrogance it just goes with the
territory christian
it does listen i lived with one i am one
i mean you know yes you know
quarterbacks
of course that's what makes them good
there's great self-confidence there is
an
arrogance you know there's the ability
to do things wrong
and you're so good at you know being
mentally strong
that you can convince yourself and your
own brain that it's really not that bad
and that's you know that's how
quarterbacks can throw three
interceptions and then just go back out
in the field and go
i'm gonna throw the ball we're gonna go
down the field and score a touchdown
here
so yeah it is part of the makeup of it
but in this case it's a negative
and it led him down a negative road here
to where now you know he's in big big
trouble
and here's the other side of it as well
beyond whoever your agent or
lawyer or managers may be the falling
out that desean watson has had with the
texans
as a practical matter means that
there really isn't someone from the
organization that's in a position
yeah to help him to speak to him the way
that he needs to be spoken to
right in order to advance his long-term
and short-term best interests there's
david culley's not in a position to do
he doesn't want to talk to david cullen
yeah
he doesn't want to talk to cal mcnair he
doesn't want to talk to jack eastwood he
doesn't want to talk to nick casario
and if that was a functional
relationship right now
maybe the coach is the one who would sit
to sean down
and have this conversation yeah i think
so and a man right about what he needs
to do because somebody needs to have
that conversation with him and desean i
know deshawn's not watching
if i was now you're in you're in the
middle of the biggest mess of your life
and i i hope he acknowledges that at
this point i hope in the past eight days
he's gone from shrugging it off to
taking it
extremely seriously because these
dominoes do potentially fall in a way
that removes your
liberty for a long period of time okay
someone needs to look him in the eye and
tell him
this is the time to take your reckoning
this is the time to resolve these claims
this is the time to make sure
it doesn't matter what you think
happened right it doesn't matter what
you believe occurred
this is the time for you to make it
right
with people who walked into a room to
give you a massage
not realizing that you were in it for
more than a massage
right and this
testimony from brian bernie proves that
you were in it for more than the massage
and and and and and your your defense
of they're trying to extort me they're
trying to blackmail me they're
they were fine with it at the time but
they're not now
that's gone yeah that's over now is the
time for you to
accept the natural consequences
of this behavior this and it wasn't one
time it was a pattern
it repeated itself over and over and
over again
to the point where he's not even sure
how many there are his agent's not sure
how many there are his lawyers not sure
how many they are and they're bracing
for more
that's how big of a of a of a deal this
became
in his life and that now's the now is
the time to now's the time to make it
right
now is the time to make it right for
yourself for them for everyone
because it's only going to get worse the
longer you dig in
it's only going to get worse and we're
only eight days into this and look at
where we are
it's only going to get worse if you keep
dug in no i'm with you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports